[Music]  Celine Dion shares a touching bit of  career advice from late husband Rene  Angelil on the voice come on wet warm up  I can do it baby  battle rounds begin next week on the NBC  hit competition show and we got a little  teaser Wednesday night of Celine in  action helping mentor team Gwen the  legendary singer shared with the group  some words of wisdom she once received  from her husband and manager my husband  is always with me he said something he  cannot be good all the time you have to  be good when it's time  [Music]  [Applause]  just before Wednesday's show aired  Celine took to Twitter to respond to  that hilarious video nicki minaj posted  to instagram lip-synching the 48 year  old singers iconic song it's all coming  back tweeting good job Nicki Minaj along  with a crying laughing emoji to which  Nicki clearly had a fangirl moment over  tweeting I love you so much  you  you